hello queers
oh my god it's so good to be here um the
glad awards is just a special uh holds a
special place uh for zeke and us because
this is where we met
2018 and we've been inseparable ever
since so who knows
tonight could be your lucky night you
could go home at a glad award and
chlamydia
it's very treatable for the bars few
pills
so glad first came into my life when i
was on survivor
with glad the help of glad's transgen
gender media team i learned how to
navigate being a very publicly trans
person regardless of whether or not i
wanted to do that um
my story with the help of vlad went on
to inspire the community
win us new allies
and even win a glad media award
tonight we've got a record 246
nominations across 30 categories
and we need this representation more
than ever we need more drama
more comedies and more love stories
so speaking of love stories
ours began four years ago here in our
favorite restaurant
the beverly hills ballroom
best best roast chicken spot in los
angeles
and nico
nico got me a at the at the after party
he got me a kettle one cocktail
he lured me into his limousine
and then he swept me off
my feet
nico your love has taught me
how to love
you are my other half
and i want to spend the rest of my life
with you
[Applause]
you